what is up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it this is something
that just I started looking into this
more and more after me and Josh and
Aubrey talked about Elon Musk on this
show if you didn't watch that go back
and check out that live from a couple
days ago where we looked at Elon Musk
you know is he somebody that we should
look up to a lot of people in the truth
or Community they think oh he he's
uncensored Twitter with X and all these
things when you really dig into who he
is and the names of his kids and what
that X symbol means and all these hidden
things he doesn't seem like somebody
that we can trust and so I just started
really looking at his connection to
Trump and how they're uniting and just
the things they're talking about and I
want to get into this stuff because it
seems like the the pieces of the puzzle
are just coming together the dots are
being connected you know like that
conspiracy theory meme where the guy
just got the red string and the pin
boards and everything but you guys tell
me you tell me if this is a reach or if
you see this the same way because what I
believe personally as a Bible believing
Christian who's watching prophecy
literally unveil before our eyes I don't
believe that we can put our trust in any
man I'm not against any person I'm not
against any political party or whatever
I'm I don't buy into the illusion of any
of the illusion of Freedom that that we
supposedly have I don't believe that our
votes are counting a third party never
wins we live in this pendulum effect
where it's always four years Republican
four years Democrat and back and forth
and it's because the system is
controlled by someone higher than the
president and I believe that is Satan
and those who work directly for Satan
this is biblical the Bible says that
Satan is the God of this world and we
know that prophecy is going to happen
nobody's going to be put in place and th
support this thing from happening it's
already too far in it the ball is
already rolling and if anything there's
a two-steps forward one step back system
so if if there's almost like an uprising
or something then the government might
say okay okay we'll we'll give you a
little bit more freedom back but they're
putting two more laws into action that
you never voted on if you have not
subscribed to this channel click
subscribe if you like this video so far
go ahead and give it a thumbs up it
really helps the algorithm thank you so
much for the love guys we're going to
get into this two years ago this was
July 1st 2022 Elon Musk said that he was
honored to meet pontiff X yesterday I
think that's weird anyway pontiff X
pontifex I don't know I just I keep
seeing this x everywhere now Twitter is
X you got uh pontiff X and you got Elon
is naming his kids with X and all this
stuff and so when we looked into X on on
the show we did with Josh from founded
Earth Brothers we found out that X is
really significant in the occult world
when when you see the Egyptians doing
this thing with their hands um it's all
about rebirth into the spirit realm and
all this stuff death and it's it's the
whole Ora Boris it's the occult system
of death and Resurrection it's the Ora
Boris it's the Phoenix out of the ashes
it's this Gnostic belief it's all the
same stuff because there's only two
sides if you're Jesus said if you're not
with me you're against me and so that's
really the whole case of it all if
you're not with Christ you're against
him and Satan has a tackle box full of
different bait if you're not into
witchcraft he's got new age if you're
not into that he's got video games if
you're not into that he's got politics
he's getting you somehow with all these
different gods and
Idols so he wasn't the only one that met
with the Pope Trump has met with a pope
every president has met with a pope
Hitler's met with a pope like every
world leader goes to meet the pope why
why don't we question these things why
do we just think oh it's just po you
know it's just PR politics or whatever
who is a Roman leader to us to America
that we would fly over there have
meetings with him shake hands and do all
these things if you read Bible prophecy
and really study it line upon line with
Daniel and Revelation and put the pieces
together there is no denying that the
papacy the Vatican is the Antichrist
Beast system if that's your first time
ever hearing that if that's just like
mind-blowing then check out a video on
this channel called who is the Beast and
what is his Mark it's about 35 minutes
and it'll walk you through all the
scriptures because there's prophetic
timelines the statue of Nebuchadnezzar
when he had that dream the head of gold
was Babylon the chest and arms of silver
were Meo Persia the Two mes and the
Persians together the belly and thighs
of brass was gree and those long iron
legs represented Rome Rome was never
defeated the feet are still of partly
iron and partly clay and that's a whole
different topic that's a mingling of
church and state because he is the
Potter we are the clay we as the body of
Christ make up the church right so
there's this corrupt dirty clay myy clay
mingled with iron which is Rome so the
last Kingdom before that rock cut
without hands smashes that statue which
is Jesus Kingdom that last kingdom is a
Roman Church state union system that's a
worldwide government and we haven't
gotten there yet but it's very
interesting that we always see these
world leaders go to meet with the Pope
and there's other things uh Revelation
gets deeper into it it's talking about
this Harlot which is a a corrupt Church
system she's sitting on a beast which is
a kingdom with seven heads which which
and the Bible says which are seven
mountains or Seven Hills you Google what
is the city of Seven Hills it's going to
say Rome so if there's a CH a corrupt
Church sitting on the Rome the city of
Rome that's Vatican and it just go it
gets way deep that she's dressed in
purple and Scarlet you look up purple
Scarlet Church all you're going to find
is Vatican and so we know that the first
Beast of Revelation is the
system now according to prophecy when
you look at who is the second beast
there's a second beast that rises up
from the earth not from the waters like
Rome did this one Rises up from the
earth and it has horns like a lamb and
speaks as a dragon the only Kingdom on
Earth that can fit all the Prophecies of
that is America because it it came up
after Rome and in the timeline and it
rose up out of the earth which
represents a desolate area because
Waters represent many peoples so the
opposite would mean the opposite so what
is the only nation that rose up after
you know in the
1700s that came up out of a desolate
area that had horns like a lamb which
represents a Christlike Spirit you know
lamb like Christ is the Lamb this nation
all talks about one nation under God you
know it's had this fac OD of being this
Christian Nation but it speaks like a
dragon how does a nation speak through
its laws so further and further down
time it is going to keep on speaking
like a dragon who else is the dragon
besides Satan is Rome it talks about the
woman standing on the moon she's clothed
with the sun and she's pregnant about to
give birth this represents the church
the pure church but it also represents
the birth of Christ because it says that
dragon
was waiting to Devour the child when it
is born and when you read all the the
surrounding text it's talking about um
Christ how it says like he'll he'll rule
the nations with an iron Rod of iron and
all these things so that Dragon
represented Rome so we know that a
dragon represents Satan but it also
represents
Rome all
right so if that's the first time
hearing it mind blown check this stuff
out America is the second beast that
gives all that takes all to worship it
creates a One World Government a one
world religion about worship of the
Beast which is Rome the second beast is
is a false prophet pointing all to
worship the first beast and so when you
see Trump and he's there with the Pope
he's no different than any of the others
you know there's I know people even in
my family there's people that literally
think that Trump is is the savior he's
the Messiah he's going to save this
country he's going to make it great
again and all these things and he's
going to thwart the New World Order
system that's what they think but he is
just another wing of the same bird left
wing right wing they're the same wings
of the same bird and he's no different
than the others we we can pretend that
you know that's how this system works
they they Pendle them real far left
till till it ticks off the right then
they get their side but we know that
there's going to have to be a Far Right
leader to bring in a new world order to
bring in a one world religion because
you have to be someone that's going to
bring worship by force that's only going
to happen with the far right right the
left they don't care anything about
religion or any of that right so we know
and according to project
2025 they want the next Republican
president which they hoped would be
Trump and here it is just like I knew it
would be that he would be like a
Christian dictator that he would be able
to inforce Christian laws or quote
unquote Christian laws because
Christianity is never forced so let's
keep going I just wanted to build the
groundwork in case some of you had never
heard this stuff before because it won't
make any sense if you if you don't know
that much then you're going to be really
lost but I hope that some of that made
sense I hope it intrigued you if you
have not heard that before Revelation
13:12 says and he exercises this is the
second beast America he America
exercises all the power of the first
Beast Rome before him and cause the
Earth and them which dwell therein to
worship the first Beast whose deadly
wound was healed so we know that Rome
fell long ago right General berier
berier he got the pope put him in Exile
and the pope died in Exile
and that was the fall of Rome but we
know that Rome has recovered Rome has
healed from that deadly wound right we
clearly see all the rulers of the world
go and meet with the leader of Rome so
there has been a healing already so
America exercised all the power of Rome
and causes the whole world to worship
Rome whose deadly wound was
healed now we see Trump he got the
presidency and for some reason
him and Elon are like Best Buds and so
elon's up there just excited and and
they're just teaming up together now
that's not a problem that's okay you can
have friends with whoever you want to
but we want to look at Elon because if
you know birds of a feather flock
together right if Elon is wicked then
what does that say about your good bud
Trump
right so we know in the last days I
believe we're living in the last days
100%
and Jesus was giving all these
prophecies they said what will be the
sign of your coming and he said for many
will come in my name saying I am Christ
and will deceive many you know that the
every Pope I'm not saying Pope Francis
I'm saying every single Pope that gets
that position of authority he proclaims
himself to be the Vicor of Christ he's
the replacement The Substitute of Christ
on Earth and you have to go to him to
ask for forgiveness for your sins and
all these things he is God on Earth
that's what he proclaimed and it says
many will say I'm the Christ and deceive
many do you know that the Catholic
church is the mo is the world's largest
quote unquote Christian
denomination deceiving many and there
have been many of these false christs
many of these popes along the way so
this is a prophecy that's been fulfilled
and and continues to
fulfill for Nations shall rise against
Nation when you look at that word in the
Greek it's it's a word that means races
and you know growing up I'm not saying
that racism has ever been dead or gone
but when I was growing up it seemed like
there wasn't this whole talk of racism
you know we had just gone through the
whole uh in the 80s there was that guy
he got beat down by the cops and that
there was all these helicopter cameras
he was a truck driver and he was saying
uh can't we all just get along that's
where that whole saying came from that
was kind of like your last Taste of of
media coverage of racism then we grew up
on Fresh Prince ofel there and uh Family
Matters and we were all getting along
and everybody was is was getting along
races were getting along but now
suddenly because the media has so much
power over the masses whatever the media
says people believe and so they made you
believe that Trump was a racist he was
the one that was in the Drake videos and
he he was he was the one that everyone
loved he was at at the wrestling matches
he had that reality show you're fired
everybody loved him he's in these rap
videos he was a he was in Home Alone he
was a celebrity everybody loved Trump
and then like that everybody said he was
a racist where did that even come from
he's hanging out with Snoop Dogg and
Drake how can you even say he's a racist
but the media has that much power and
then they start tearing down statues and
all these things and I I'm not ignorant
I know that these founding fathers and
these wars and stuff that they were
slave owners and all that I get that
what I'm saying is how the media can
flip a switch and now all of a sudden
people want to take action and cause
riots in the street stre and throw
bricks at bu and and windows and
everything and all this stuff was funded
by elitists like George Soros people
were going into the City and filming
with their own phones like I don't know
why there's a pallet here full of bricks
but it just got dropped off and there's
one around the corner and all of a
sudden there's a bus dropping off a
whole bunch of protesters right here
this stuff was all staged and rigged up
this was this was
systematic so we saw we see that now
there's these racial divisions going on
famines this was in 2023 and you see all
these different nations and how much
famine is going on right
now pestilences we know that we just got
through at least one of the waves or
whatever I you know they're they're
going to come out with something new
it's going to be the I don't even know
if I can say certain words but monkeys
and it's kind of like chicken pox but
you know so I'm kind of coding these
words but there's always some new strain
of something it was always bird flu
swine flu ecoli all this stuff and then
we had Co and it shut the whole world
down overnight Everybody Must mask up
this vaccine is pretty much mandated and
uh now they're having to pay people back
who lost their jobs for for refusing it
because they know it wasn't safe and
effective like they said pestilences
worldwide earthquakes Jesus said
there'll be earthquakes in in natural
disasters in diverse places and we know
when I say natural I'm talking about
quote unquote natural disasters that are
happening worldwide so all these things
are being
fulfilled we we got the many false
Christ we got the racial division we got
the famines we got the pestilences we
got the earthquakes in diverse places
this map is showing you like just two
years all the yellow is or all the red
is like that day all the the Orange is a
week ago and and the yellow is two two
years or something like that so all
those earthquakes happen in a short
amount of
time the world is in
chaos this is what has to happen the
world has to reach a place of
desperation before they will cry out for
a messiah the stage is being set and
primed and ready to receive the false
Messiah Satan impersonating Christ we
know that Satan is going to counterfeit
the second coming of Christ and he's
going to deceive millions and we know
there's other things that are going on
spiritual phenomenons uh paranormal
things like the military having these uh
meetings about UFOs and
extraterrestrials and we they're saying
that we communicate with non-human
intelligences and we don't know what to
call them but they're real they're here
and there's no denying it anymore
there's no covering it up they're saying
this is real and we need to do something
about it we need to get it out there
whatever when I believed this stuff
growing up the Paranormal I was looked
at as like some C but now the military
is saying these things are real this is
Paranormal stuff Supernatural spiritual
stuff is happening in our world today
the world is in chaos it's primed and
ready for Satan to step out and say I'm
your savior I can fix all this stuff
lying signs and wonders
fire from heaven all this stuff but
first before that happens it's going to
take a one world extreme
right president to bring a in America in
America there's going to have to be a
extreme rightwing president to
enforce a form of worship in this state
first that will reach the whole world
because we'll find out that this is for
the betterment of humanity it's going to
help climate change because you're going
to rest one day a week you're going to
give Mother Earth a break uh Elon he's
pushing all the green movement stuff all
this stuff is going to help climate
change this is how they're going to get
everybody
involved so the world is in chaos primed
and ready for a messiah and a lot of
people are thinking that Trump he's the
man he's the man for for the plan
because especially with this this quote
unquote
assassination this attempt I question
everything if you don't if you don't
realize that go go and watch one of the
videos in the live it's called Uh
believe the media trust the media and
I'm going to show you 100% proof of
event after event after event that were
lies that nothing added up that all of
it was fake and and people say I don't
trust the government I I don't believe
the news and yet when you say these
things they get offended and and think
how dare you question this event well
I'm not questioning real life events yes
evil things happen in the world but if
it's on the news and it makes mainstream
media Nationwide news I question it if
there's you know
if somebody gets skimmed across the ear
drops down comes up with a bloody ear
and the security guards aren't even
making them stay down I question things
like that shortly after that there was
not even a scar a scab
anything but because of this attempt
maybe two attempts they say because of
that all the more people were like he's
a man someone's trying to stop him this
is where it's misinformation
disinformation this is where they're
playing both sides they're creating a
hero for you he's the man that that the
evil people want to stop so he must be
voted in and he won with flying colors
by the way they the person that they
gave you as a another option really
wasn't going to win
anyway but I don't believe the votes
even
counted this is what I see going
on this is straight up
idolatry if you don't see this this is
Will for ignorance This Is Blindness if
you can't see that this is idolatry when
you look to a man like this this is like
the kings in the Bible days when they're
like this is the voice of a god and not
a
man these look at these people looking
up in adoration and putting a bandage on
their
ear as they just gaze up at this man
this is the golden calf this is the the
statue the golden image bow before your
image and I want you to pay attention to
his hand posture because that comes
in so this this makes me think of
Communism all the way because right now
we know in America a lot of Americans
know that communism is trying to creep
in but they think it's just from the
Democrats they think oh don't don't let
a Democrat win don't let Obama win
because he's a communist he's gonna
bring communism into this nation guess
what they're both the same bird two
wings of the same feather whether you're
right-wing or left wing it's the same
bird so it doesn't matter if Trump's in
abortion is always going to be legal it
doesn't matter if Trump's in the agenda
is still rolling out now when I see
communist China and they're holding up
these big banners of their leader and
then I see what's happening in our
country with Trump not not some democrat
with Trump I see the same thing there's
nothing different here can you see it
can you see that there is nothing
different about these two
images now look at the hand posture this
is the Communist fist Obama did it lyen
did it in the top right corner you see
lynen with that fist you see it with the
black lives matter movement they're
they're going to get you that's what I'm
saying Satan has a tackle box full of
bait if you're not into politics he's
going to get you with black lives matter
if you're not into communism and you
think it's the Democrat he's going to
get you with the Republican it's a trick
it's all a mind game this is sorcery
they have you all Bewitched to where you
think that this actually matters which
side you're on and it's all divide and
conquer it's all division all it is
about divide and conquer we want to
divide the race we want to divide the
genders we want to divide the politics
we want to divide everything and get you
all fighting amongst yourselves because
that's the way they stay in power when
we are not on the same side and we can't
agree on anything they stay in power and
when we think our votes matter and ah I
got my man Mr uh
Republican I'm good now everything's
good now and people literally think that
I remember the interview with the lady
when uh Obama won she she was on camera
and said I w't have to about paying my
mortgage I won't have to worry about
trying to get gas in my car she thought
Obama was going to pay her mortgage and
fill up her gas tank that's how much
people put their trust in political
figures and Men it's it's
sorcery now this isn't just some one-off
picture of trump I I just showed you one
I looked up Trump Raised Fist and it's
tons of pictures especially right now
and it's all because they think he's
saying oh yeah I resist you know they
tried to they tried to shoot me but
they're not going to win and all this
stuff but this is the Communist fist
because what the plan is is a one world
communist
government so this was taken shortly
this picture was shortly after
his being grazed by a bullet and had to
wear a giant bandage on it now he
doesn't even have a scab a scar anything
and when he was asked about it he said
oh I'm a fast healer yep it was like a
week later a week dude you're I can pick
a zit and still have a scab on my face
for longer than a week this dude was
skimmed by a assault rifle
bullet and nothing nothing is wrong with
his ear that's not even what I want to
point out I want to point out his hat
because we know these people are all
about numerology symbology the occult
these are the rulers of the world I
don't know what kind of words anymore
get flagged and triggered but these are
the illuminated ones if you get my drift
these are the Masons and all that stuff
and they love numerology they love
special dates with those numbers they
love putting those numbers in Your
Entertainment it's all numbers to them
numerology astrology the occult world is
full of this
stuff so check out his hat because he
was the 45th president and now he's the
47th president I don't think it's a
coincidence because I don't even believe
the votes matter I think it was all set
up coincidentally it's just a
coincidence if you add the numbers four
and five together you get nine if you
add the numbers four and seven together
you get 11 so he literally has 91 on his
hat I don't think that's just paying
tribute to some thing that happened you
know some historical
event I believe it's much more Sinister
than that this is order out of chaos
this is the Phoenix Rising From the
Ashes because if you know what those
numbers mean the numbers nine the
numbers 11 and what they mean when you
combine them together it's the whole
agenda that's why that's why 911 is so
important to these people that's why
they want to give it to you every year
never forget 911 it's all numerology
they want to put it in your face they
want to get you with their subliminal
witchcraft every year never forget
911 and what do you do when you when
you're in trouble call 911 they always
got to put it in your face everywhere
why because it's so deep the number nine
the numer numerological number nine now
this is from chat GPT this is not like
Wikipedia chat GPT is scouring the
entire information of the world and
giving you a a Juiced version of it it
and this is what it said it said number
nine represents completion endings and
transformation wait a minute completion
of what ending of what
transformation it is often seen as the
last number before the cycle begins a
new okay try tying to themes of judgment
culmination or the end of an era what
happened after 9/11 that's when all of
our freedom started really going away
right being stripped big time the
Patriot Act they give it this friendly
name the Patriot Act oh it's I'm a
patriot I yeah I want to get fris and
scanned and metal detected every time I
go through the TSA I want them to just
fill me up this was when your freedom
started going away being stripped
911 why because it was the beginning of
a transformation it was the end of one
era and the beginning of a new era it is
also associated with spiritual
enlightenment
ult Ultra ISM and Universal
Consciousness Universal Consciousness
this is the age of Aquarius this is one
world religion this is where all this is
coming to this is luciferianism the One
World conscious Universal Consciousness
whether it's new age or ult or whatever
it is is all about worship to
Lucifer Satan
however in the context of the occult
nine can symbolize the culmination of a
ritual or the birthing of something new
through
destruction wait a minute wait the the
beginning a new
era a new era of universal Consciousness
that
starts with
destruction starts with
destruction what happened at 9/11 that
was a
ritual that was an occult ritual that
brought in the new era this stuff is so
deep
guys number 11 considered a master
number in numerology 11 is linked to
intuition spiritual insight and the
Gateway between the material and the
spiritual world this is why they love
Halloween so much and push that too
because that's when they say the veil is
the thinnest between the spiritual world
and physical world 11 Okay so you got
the beginning of a new Universal
Consciousness starting with destruction
with number nine and now you got the
Gateway between the material in the
spiritual worlds it also represents
Duality and balance two pillars good and
evil male and female when you look at
the
Masonic uh apron that's one of the
things you'll see those pillars with the
Globes on top there's pillars on either
side that's what this is about that's
11 Duality that's the balance of Good
and Evil the yin and the yang this stuff
is worldwide this is a worldwide
deception Duality is not good the Bible
says that we should not fellowship with
Darkness light cannot mingle with
Darkness it says in a cult context 11
often symbolizes A disruption of order
okay wait a minute A disruption of order
so there was order but now we're going
to bring in some new era
representing the chaos that precedes the
creation of something new
precedes precedes means before so if you
got not after precedes so there was
chaos that precedes a new order of
Duality and a Gateway between spiritual
worlds Alistar Crowley a prominent
occultist emphasized the number 11 as
being tied to Magic will and the
manipulation of reality oh my goodness
the manipulation of reality are we
dealing with something today that is
like a blending and we can't even tell
if it's real or not right AI like we're
literally virtual reality metaverse all
these things augmented reality we're
blending things and it's never been this
way when I was growing up it was VHS and
Nintendo we dreamed of having VR
headsets and now we're in the world
where you just type something and it
comes to life and you can animate it and
you can put yourself in you can immerse
yourself in that world I see videos and
pictures I I understand I I mess with AI
images a lot so I can usually kind of
spot it out but if you didn't know if
you're not familiar with AI and what it
looks like it's impossible to tell the
difference especially now it's getting
worse and worse well it's getting better
and better which is worse for us but AI
as good as it is now is the worst it's
going to be it only gets better every
single second it's evolving itself it
gets better every moment of every
day we this is what it's saying it's
saying a manipulation of reality now
notice it says magic with a K that's
Alistar Crowley's magic I believe these
people are Sorcerers that have Bewitched
the world into thinking oh trump our man
he's going to save the nation no you've
been tricked your Spellbound by this by
these magicians who are manipulating
your reality another thing not just AI
but your reality of what's real 911 oh
my goodness or that event oh we need to
take the guns oh he almost got
shot manipulating your reality oh my
vote counts
right that's not
reality now combine that nine with that
11 symbolic combinations of nine and 11
when 9 and 11 are placed together the
numbers can signif can signify a
transition through what
destruction a transition through
destruction the ending of an old order
and the opening of a gateway to a new
paradigm are you guys hearing this man
are you guys hearing this something had
to be
destroyed like
towers for this ritual for these
magicians that are deceiving the whole
world and it was the begin it was the
ending of an old order which was like
man we grew up in my time period in the
90s and everything whether you lived
like a Christian or not you believed in
God oh I believe in Jesus I'm going to
heaven you could be drinking a beer uh
Sleeping with the girl that you're not
married to and smoking cigarettes and
weed and all that stuff and oh I believe
in Jesus I'm going to heaven and now the
shift has happened to where if you're a
Christian you're a bigot and you're a
hater and all these things a shift has
happened the old order of things the way
God made it the end of the old order and
an opening of a gateway to a new
paradigm the paradigm shift is
happening this mirrors the occult idea
that chaos or destruction is
necessary to create order or manifest a
new reality are you kidding me a new
reality dude this goes like Way Beyond
if I would have read this 10 years ago I
wouldn't have even thought of AI or
known that that kind of reality could
exist but a new
reality chaos or destruction is
necessary to create it the pairing of
911 is also associated with the idea of
an emergency or crisis which is
interesting that a crisis happened
symbolizing sudden upheaval meant to
shift Collective Consciousness oh my
goodness so if there's an emergency and
a crisis and it's associated with the
combining of N9 and 11 it's meant for a
collective
Consciousness Collective
Consciousness one world
religion this is what the Bible
literally talked about we're seeing it
happen today it's crazy
notice that those buildings are are
literally 11 those buildings aren't just
two buildings that were next to each
other they're called the Twin Towers now
L listen to this twin pillars and 11 in
esoteric Traditions the number 11 is
often depicted as two pillars like the
Masonic imagery like I was talking about
those pillars on and the and the
Freemasons these these buildings this
was a a plan from the beginning this was
never just hey it wouldn't it be neat to
put two buildings side by side and call
them the Twin Towers this is all
esoteric ritualistic
magic the in Masonic imagery of Boaz and
jocken at the entrance of Solomon's
Temple so this goes all the way back to
Solomon's Temple because that's what the
Masons believe they believe that they're
going to rebuild Solomon's Temple and
they embraced Solomon because in
esoteric writings they say that Solomon
had a ring with a hexagram on it that
gave him the power to control demons I
mean I don't I know Solomon got into
some crazy stuff and I hope he repented
but I don't know about the truth behind
that stuff that's just what these
esoteric writings say that's what these
Sorcerers believe
in these pillars represent the gateway
to higher wisdom and initiation into
hidden knowledge
we should not be searching after hidden
knowledge guys we can read the Bible and
we can read prophecy and see what's
going on but when you start looking for
hidden knowledge that's when you start
getting into trouble their destruction
symbolically or literally there what did
what did it just say their destruction
what destruction destruction of what
what's the context of the conver of the
of the context here is the two
pillars the
destruction of the two pillars
whether symbolically or literally can
signify the fall of the old and the rise
of the new are you are you guys hearing
this the destruction of the two pillars
which represent 11 is is mandatory in
order to bring about a
new
order this is crazy man the Phoenix
cycle we talked a little bit about the
Phoenix 911 is sometimes interpreted
through the lens of the Phoenix
archetype which represents death and
rebirth through what Through Fire wait a
minute death and rebirth Through Fire
these towers came down with fire now we
got one big building in its place a
rebirth that's the Phoenix rising up out
of the ashes that one giant pillar is
the New Order they even call it oh do
they I don't want to I don't want
fact check me guys I'm pretty sure that
that Tower is called the One World Tower
oh my goodness thank you Lord for
discernment things are just still coming
dots just continue to get connected I
just I had to just go ahead and go live
because I'm never going to stop this
thing just keeps
going death and rebirth through fire so
those twins came down through fire and
were resurrected as a new world Tower
One World Tower the destruction on a
Grand scale symbolized by nine is viewed
as a sacrifice oh my God as a
sacrifice or ritual to bring forth a
rebirth or New Order symbolized by 11 as
a portal or
threshold can you guys see
this can you guys see that it says that
in order to bring about this new world
order in order to make that happen they
had to destroy symbolically or literally
the twin
pillars and then there was by fire and
then there was going to be a phoenix
coming up out of the
ashes as a one world
Tower and it was going to be the a
rebirth or a new order dude the it's
right there a new
order this stuff is so deep guys
whoa that's exactly what happened two
pillars that represent 11 fell because
of fire and
explosives and this is order out of
chaos this is what these people believe
that's what these Sorcerers believe
order out of chaos because when you
bring people to their lowest and they're
in panic and they're in fear and they
don't know where their next meal is
going to come from they don't they can't
trust their neighbor
that's how you get order quote unquote
order the kind of order that they want
this is how you make it
happen and the Phoenix out of the
ashes so it
continues dualities in 9/11 the number
nine and 11 can be seen as an
encompassing as encompassing dualities
destruction and creation that's exactly
what destruction the destruction of of a
former America that was based on freedom
and all these things you got to destroy
that because you're going to create a
new world order a One World Government
Chaos and Order order out of chaos
physical and spiritual Realms you're
putting the two together occultists who
focus on numerology might view this
combination as a potent symbol as a
potent symbol of manipulating reality
using ritual Acts or symbolic events to
bring about the systemic
shift if you can't see that this right
here was a ritual that manipulated your
reality a ritual or an
act a symbolic act a ritual act or
symbolic events to bring about a
systematic
shift
ma'am so the phrase order out of
chaos and it is most commonly attributed
to the Latin phrase Ordo
[__] which is the motto of the Scottish
right of Freemasonry signifying the idea
of creating order from a state of
disorder the concept itself is deeply
rooted in ancient creation myths across
VAR various cultures where a Divine
Force brings order to a primordial chaos
the Latin phrase is Oro OBO I just
wanted to show you that this is based
where it comes from is from the Scottish
right and it's all about creating order
out of
disorder the phrase Phoenix Rising From
the Ashes it sounds so so cool and
pretty you know it's like hey you know I
went through something hard and I'm Like
a Phoenix rising out of the ashes it
says a Phoenix Rising From the Ashes is
a metaphor that represents rebirth
renewal and hope After experiencing
difficult times sounds so lovely right
except that it's a cult that's the same
thing the or Boris the snake biting its
tail same thing it comes from the Greek
myth of the Phoenix a mythical bird that
is reborn From the Ashes of its
predecessors the Phoenix is an is an
immortal bird that is associated with
the sun always comes back to worship of
the Sun Sunday
worship the worship of the sun is
everywhere if you if you guys want to
check out some of our past videos uh
this goes into androgyny the dark
origins of androgyny who is the Rainman
all this stuff Bal was the sun
everything points back to the sun when
we went to Washington DC everything was
the sun everywhere that's what all this
is about Sun worship that's what the the
Lady Liberty is about Sun worship that's
Helios
so listen to this uh never waste a good
crisis and when it comes to the economic
crisis don't waste it when it it can
have a very positive impact on climate
change and energy secur energy security
and that's what we're trying to do yeah
we're trying to do something positive
with this crisis well where did the
crisis come from was it a manufactured
crisis what what is this even talking
about here here's the guy who originally
said it you never want a serious crisis
to go to waste and what I mean by that
it's an opportunity to do things that
you think you could not do before these
people are so bold that they'll tell you
to your face we're going to take that
chaos and we're going to create
something big out of it we're going to
create something new out of it something
that you could never dream could happen
imagine being a human being and thinking
that you could create a one world
enslavement that sounds pretty big but
thanks to manufactured chaos we can
create order out of chaos
man so I thought this was really
interesting Elon my boy Elon he said I'm
dark Maga Elon Musk speaks at Trump
rally I'm not just Maga I'm dark Maga
what is Maga just for anybody that might
not know make America great again man I
don't think there's coincidences
anywhere the whole thing these people
are sitting around in a smoke filled
room like okay how can we how can we
manipulate them how can we get them to
chant our witchcraft you know how can we
put these people under our spell let's
come up with a Maga we gotta use Maga we
gotta use 9911 we gotta use Maga and
make America great again that's right
with with uh Obama he was saying um yes
yes we can yes we can and when you
played the speeches backwards of the
whole crowd saying yes we can it was
thank you Satan thank you Satan this is
not coincidence how can this stuff
happen over and over and over how can it
always be dark and evil how come Obama
speech didn't say give to the poor give
to the poor backwards it never does it's
always Satan it's always Maga it's
always Phoenix From the Ashes it's
always 911 all these occult things right
what is the word Maga what is the word
Maga a witch look at this this is from
Cambridge English Italian dictionary
which it's a noun another word for which
is right there circled Maga it's not
just there the Sanskrit dictionary Maga
a priest of the what first first it says
it's a magician don't think this is like
you know Illusionist magician is a
sorcerer it's a witch it's a
warlock and the second definition says a
priest of the
son again with the
sun oh and at the very bottom it says a
priest of the sun there it is
twice now if you simply just go to
Google and use the trans the translator
in Italian magga means Sorceress in
Latin magga means witch in Polish magga
means magician and I didn't even try
anymore I mean it there's others I'm
sure but it's a sorcerer it's a
sorceress with
magician Maga is it a coincidence that
that is Trump's slogan Maga and that
Elon comes out here and says I'm not
just Maga I'm dark Maga I'm a dark witch
a black magician is what he's
saying Revelation 18:23 says and the
light of a candle shall shine no more at
all in thee and the voice of the
bridegroom and of the Bride shall be
heard no no more at all in thee this is
a strong warning like we're going to
reach a place where we're so entrenched
in Witchcraft and the illusion of this
politics and all this stuff under their
spell that if we don't wake up and come
out of Babylon we're not even going to
be ready for Christ's return our candle
will not shine and it says for thy
Merchants were the Great Men of the
Earth for by th sorceries were all
nations
deceived so we know that there's coming
a time where the whole world is going to
be deceived by sorcery and we just saw
this Maga sorceress we just saw what 911
was all about sorcery and ritual magic
and all this stuff and who's going to do
it who's going to be the rulers and the
Great Men of the Earth the merchants who
are the
merchants they're the rich men of the
world
and do you know who the richest man in
the world is Elon
Musk can you imagine even having that
title I'm the richest man on Earth on
Earth not in America not in a certain
State money is power if he is the
richest man on earth there's nothing he
can't have there's nothing he can't do
he could go up to any person and say
you're going to do this for me and if he
says no way well I'll just hire someone
to assassinate you you are like a god on
Earth Elon Musk the richest man in the
world is teamed up with
Trump but is does that necessarily mean
he's a bad guy just because he's rich I
don't know but it says the merchants
were the Great Men of the world and
they're the ones that are doing this
sorcery the sorcerers
so here check this out did you know that
we're in the year of the dragon
according to uh the
Chinese astrology basically it says the
Year of the Dragon is
2024 we're in the year of the dragon and
it began on February 10th 2024 so okay
well it's only 2024 right well you see
down at the bottom it says Dragon 2024
well what are we fixing to enter into
the year of the snake are you kidding me
so we went from the year of the dragon
and now we're entering into the year of
the snake you cannot make this stuff up
man I believe we're in the last days I
believe Jesus coming soon I believe 2025
is significant when they're talking
about project 2025 and they want the
Republican leader to have dictatorship
and he can enforce any kind of religious
laws that's a red flag and we just
entered from the dragon to the snake in
Revelation 12 n says and the Great
Dragon was cast out that old serpent who
is this dragon and serpent called the
devil and Satan which deceives the whole
world again the deception of the whole
world he was cast out into the Earth and
his angels were cast out with him Satan
is here Satan ain't down in some fiery
pit underneath our feet he's roaming
around on Earth he's flying around in
the skies looking like alien
visitors chaos is about to
ensue and you're going to see that more
and more as we talk about this because
you have to bring you have to bring the
nation to their knees so that they're
ready to embrace a cosmic savior an
antichrist who's going to promise peace
and safety I forgot to put that verse in
this SL in these slides but when they
shall say peace and safety sudden
destruction comes upon them like
travails Upon A Woman these are signs of
the times when the first
chaos uh pestilences false Christ
natural disasters all these things then
when they say peace and safety that's
coming up that is coming that's the next
step on the timeline we're in chaos and
it's going to get worse but peace and
safety is going to be
promised this is crazy guys is it a
coincidence that Trump's right-hand man
everything he does is symbolic of Satan
the Dragon capsule come on why didn't
you call it like something else like why
it have to be the
dragon I don't think this is just pulled
out of a hat Elon Musk a lot of us know
that he was wearing this thing for
Halloween this demonic satanic outfit
that has an inverted cross on the head
of a baffet and it said that Elon Musk
was mocked for claiming for claiming
Christianity is under attack while
wearing a baffet armor with an upside
down cross on his profile pig isn't it
ironic that he's like defending
Christianity while wearing an upside
down cross in a baffet this is like
Antichrist all the way now don't get me
Twisted on this presentation I'm not
pointing out any one man as an
antichrist Antichrist is a spirit that
Jesus said there's there was many
Antichrist even
now Antichrist is a spirit but we know
that that spirit is going to create a
one world religion and a one world
government and a One World Currency that
can be shut off at any time because you
won't be able to buy or sell all of that
is
coming his one of his logos SpaceX logo
is a goat okay so you got the
dragon the
goat and then some fans spent hundreds
of thousands of dollars building this
golden calf a Golden Goat move over
golden calf meet Elon musk's Golden
Goat I I didn't I didn't like remember
the price but it was hundreds of
thousands of dollars spent on this
abomination of Elon musk's head on a
goat riding a rocket that says Elon goat
what kind of crazy world do we live
in and then he's got falcon Space X has
the Falcon why a f why a
dragon why a
goat why a
falcon Horus the Egyptian god Horus in
ancient Egyptian religion a God in the
form of a falcon wait a minute Horus is
a falcon whose right eye was the son or
morning star representing power and
quintessence and whose left ey was the
moon or evening star representing
healing Falcon Cults which were in
evidence from late pre- pre-dynastic
times were widespread in Egypt do you
know that the Eye of Horus is the symbol
of the New World Order and he's using a
falcon I just how is this a coincidence
guys how can it be always
evil coincidentally always
coincidentally evil it's not this is
this is prophecy guys this is not
conspiracy theory this is Bible prophecy
anyone who's watching this if you
believe the Bible put those Bible lenses
on and realize what is happening all
around us right now this is not
coincidence there's no man coming to
save the nation this is all part of the
plan part of Satan's plan and we know
Jesus is coming soon and I'm excited
about that it is scary there's some
scary things but I'm excited about Jesus
coming in my lifetime Elon Musk right
after Trump won and everything and he
was hanging out with him he posted a
picture of himself and Trump with the
caption novas Oro
sorum that is New World Order in Latin
novas means new Ordo means order order
and
secular secular worldly World New World
Order why did he post that why would why
are you the richest man in the world
that has a dragon and a goat and wears a
satanic outfit and you name your thing
Falcon based on Horus and at me gallan
2018 you're wearing a jacket that says
novas or sorum on the
back it's all just coincidence guys he's
a good guy we should
know he he's a good guy he's on Trump's
side I'm not saying either one of them
are good I'm saying we got to stop being
blinded by the wolves and sheep's
clothing are we going to fall for this
are we going to literally
just I feel like at this point we're
just doing it to ourselves like oh
yeah all right so the Communist handbook
because New World Order is worldwide
communism and Carl Marx Fred Frederick
Eng Les made this Communist Manifesto
and they had 10 points they said the
only way you can get communism to happen
is if you fulfill these 10 points first
abolition of private property so you
can't own look I I'm buying a house but
it's never going to be mine I all every
year I'm gonna have to pay property tax
every year it's never going to be mine
so that's already been taken heavy so if
there's ever a time where I lose a job
or even if I paid the last penny on this
house and lost my job it could get taken
away from me it's not mine it's like
rent forever you you you'll own nothing
and like it that's what they
say heavy Progressive or graduated
income tax so take more money from
people who have higher income take more
okay so they're going to take more money
from you if you make more money they're
going to take more money from me that's
happening abolish rights of
inheritance wow State acquires citizen
property citizens property upon their
death families no longer get heirlooms
or
inheritance I I honestly I don't know
too much about this but I have heard
that if you don't have a
will that's what happens if you don't
write a will specifying and I haven't
wrote a will not that I got anything to
give away but it's like who's sitting
around writing a will and if you haven't
then your family's probably not going to
get your stuff number four confiscate
property owned by immigrants and Rebels
these citizens no longer have rights to
their
property establish a National Bank oh
that's a big one we're about to talk
about that establish a national bank so
you're talking about One World
Currency nationally controlled
Communications and transport are you
kidding me commun are our Communications
n nationally controlled yes
dude Google and Facebook and YouTube can
censor anything I search stuff dude when
I used to go down the conspiracy theory
Rabbit Hole in 2012 and look up all the
cool stuff on on YouTube and Google you
try to look up that stuff now and all
you're going to get as debunk videos I
mean it's crazy our communication and
transport is nationally controlled you
cannot you can't even leave the country
without a passport you can't enter into
certain areas you can't fly in certain
air spaces yes our transport
is uh is controlled by the national I I
mean there's certain places you can't
go government ownership of means of
production factories land and natural
resources so I guess if you're a
farmer actually you know what I saw this
I
saw in 2020 around the beginning of the
whole pandemic thing in 2020
I saw people on camera Farmers literally
opening up envelopes and it was a letter
from the government that said we will
buy your farm from you and if you don't
take our offer we're going to burn down
your crop that was for real dude are you
kidding me and this says government
ownership of the means of
production Industrial and agricultural
armies everyone is liable to
work I I gotta be honest I don't really
understand that one redistribute
population eliminate sovereignty of
state and town by redist by
redistributing people so they don't want
you to have any kind of authority in
your own State like Hey we're Texas
we're going to make we're going to do
our own thing they don't want
that um and that's in the process of
happening free and public education yeah
I went to Public Schools growing up I'm
so glad I didn't go to I'm not going to
public school now because of what they
teach now but I was homeschooled during
middle school and I missed the whole
Evolution stuff brainwashing but yeah
free public education I wonder why so
you can send the parents off to work
because they're in a system where they
have to pay for their house and all
these things they can't even make bills
because groceries are so high both
parents have to work and and get on the
rat race wheel and what so we're going
to send our you can't homeschool your
kids we ain't got time for that put them
in the public school system that's where
they learn Evolution and that there's 86
genders and that you can change your
gender and all these things yeah that's
where we want the state to raise your
kids that's what they want that's part
of this Communist
Manifesto Elon Musk said this on look at
this website World government's Summit
World Government Summit Elon Musk on why
the world needs a universal basic income
un so the world needs a universal basic
income why let's listen it will be fewer
and fewer jobs that a robot cannot do
better what to do about mass
unemployment this is going to be a
massive social Challenge and I think
ultimately we will have to have some
kind of universal basic income I don't
think we're going to have a choice
Universal basic income Universal basic
income I think it's going to be
necessary so to mean that unemployed
people will be paid across the globe
yeah because there is no job machine
robot is taking over these are not uh
things that I think that I wish would
happen these are think simply things
that I think probably will happen if my
assessment is correct and they probably
will happen then we need to say what are
we going to do about it and I think some
kind of a universal basic income is
going to be necessary the output of
goods and services will be extremely
high um so with automation there will
come
abundance almost everything will get
very cheap I think we'll just end up
doing a universal basic income it's
going to be necessary the the the harder
challenge much harder challenge is how
do people then have meaning like a lot
of people they derive their meaning from
their employment so if you're not needed
if there's not a need for your labor how
do you what's the meaning do you do you
have meaning do you feel useless these
are much that's a much harder problem to
deal with he thinks it's a much harder
problem to deal with that people aren't
going to have meaning because they don't
have
jobs that's that's kind of a side issue
but if you miss kind of what he was
saying there he's saying because of
AI evolving rapidly uh more faster than
anything that robots are going to take
over jobs that might sound far-fetched
to you but if you got self-driving cars
you don't need a no no more Ubers no
more Uber Eats no more Uber drivers no
more valet
no more
taxis if you we already are our own
cashier at the grocery store and at
Walmart remember when they used to have
aisles and there was always there's a
cashier everyone you had to stand in
line no now it's like two people
watching 20 cash
registers if you are an artist AI is
getting better and better at Art every
day nobody needs to pay some artist on
Fiverr anymore you just pay 20 bucks a
month for chat GPT and you can have any
art you want music musicians you lost
your job I can make any song I want
using sunno and right now is the worst
it's ever going to be it's getting
better and better every day uh what else
is it restaurant employees are being
replaced by robots by AI you go through
a drive-thru and AI is asking for your
order it knows what you're saying think
about it when you ask um Siri hey Siri
blah blah blah blah blah
this thing knows what you're talking
about so if you go to a drive-thru and
you say oh I want a you know potato soft
taco and a bean burrito it knows what
you're saying they don't need a a a
person doing the drive-through anymore
then you go in
okay jobs are getting taken away so Elon
Musk is saying because jobs are getting
taken by AI there's going to be a
problem many people thousands if not
millions of people are going to lose
their jobs
overnight that's going to cause
really chaotic
effects when people can't
eat one day two day three day a week
chaos chaa and and so he's saying we
have to do something we have to and he's
at a world he's at the world government
Summit he's not a politician he's not a
president he's not a king the merchants
will be the Great Men of the world they
will deceive the World by sorcery Elon
has as much power As Trump if you
believe that Trump has any kind of power
at all no he's a puppet he's a puppet
for the ones that are in control for
Satan and so elon's got as much power as
he does and he's saying you know what we
need Elon can change the whole world he
can say look everybody needs to have a
universal basic
income worldwide communism that's
exactly what it is you left your job
with Google and Par because you say you
want to focus solely on your concerns
about AI you've spoken out saying that
AI could manipulate or possibly figure
out a way to kill humans H H how could
it kill humans well event if it gets to
be much smarter than us it'll be very
good at manipulation because it will
have learned that from us so what do we
do do we just need to pull the plug on
it right now do we need to put in Far
More restrictions and and and uh back
stops on this what how do we solve this
problem I'm not an expert on how to do
regulation I'm just a scientist who
suddenly realize that these things are
getting smarter than us um and I want to
sort of blow the whistle and say we
should worry seriously about how we stop
these things getting control over us um
and it's going to be very hard and I
don't have the solutions I wish I did I
don't think we can stop the progress I
didn't sign the petition saying we
should stop working on AI because if
people in America stop people in China
wouldn't there have been some
whistleblowers who have been warning
about the dangers of AI over the past
few years one of them um timy gabu was
forced out of Google for voicing his
concerns uh looking back on it do you
wish that you had stood Behind These
whistleblowers more I think it's easier
to voice concerns if you leave the
company first their concerns aren't as
existentially serious as the idea of
these things getting more intelligent
than us in taking over Steve wak one of
the co-founders of Apple is also
speaking out about the dangers he fears
will come from AI take a listen AI is
another more powerful tool and it's
going to be used by those people um know
for basically uh really evil purposes
and I hate to see technology being used
that way it shouldn't be and some
probably some types of Regulation are
are needed but for the existential
threat of AI taking over we're all in
the same boat it's bad for all of us and
so we might be able to get China and the
US to agree on things like that it's
like nuclear weapons if there's a
nuclear war we all lose and it's the
same if these things take over so since
we're all in the same same boat we
should be able to get agreement between
China and the US and things like that
props to this guy because he quit when
he started having a moral conscience
about what was going to happen with AI
he quit he's blowing the whistle he's
like this stuff's dangerous and it's
going to destroy Humanity
soon this is not we're not talking about
oh yeah in the year 5000 this isn't even
10 years
away it's going to take away jobs it's
going
to maybe think
hm humans are really the problem on this
Earth we should just annihilate them
that's the storyline of Terminator like
Skynet realized it was it became
self-aware and it realized oh humans are
The Pest of the earth so I'm going to
just press the button and launch all the
nukes and Destroy
Humanity now I don't know if it's going
to be like that I think it's going to be
way different I don't think we're going
to have Terminators going in the street
killing people maybe at least on a some
small scale but I believe it's just
going to [__] our economy to where
you can't eat and that's what's going to
happen and then the false Messiah will
come Satan will come in as Christ and
deceive millions and he's going to come
as this angel of Light as Christ and
he's going to be doing lying signs and
wonders bringing fire down from heaven
Miracles it says that these Miracle
working demons is what the Revelation
says Miracle working demons we're gonna
these demons whether they come in the
form of aliens or Cosmic Christ or
whatever it is they're going to get rid
of pandemics they're going to fix
climate change they're going to heal
people of diseases that we know are
curable but there being hidden the cures
are being hidden they're going to be
able to fix cancer and all oh I hope
that didn't flag me you're not allowed
to say that word anymore they're going
to cure the things of Earth these
lying deceivers these Miracle working
demons lying wonders signs and lying
wonders and this is what the stage is
being set up for I see somebody just
unsubscribed all right I'm not sure why
but thanks for announcing
it this is where we're going New World
Order Bible prophecy this is coming true
if you don't like Bible prophecy please
unsubscribe because that's what this
channel is about bringing the truth
check out this video Ai and automation
have arrived and they're going to
transform Society forever from cashiers
to CEOs more jobs are getting replaced
by the machines every day so what are
the various predictions for how bad the
damage is really going to be well
there's lots of different estimates but
even the most conservative still mean
that millions of jobs will get replaced
in the short term it isn't looking good
it's generally agreed that tens of
millions of jobs will be lost over the
next decade to AI we're at a Crossroads
right now there's two main ways this can
all play out the first option could just
be complete disaster Society continues
on no checks are in place big Tech AI
companies get out of control ethics
departments are continually stripped and
lacking government regulation means we
enter into a technocracy companies will
pretend it's business as usual but over
time they'll cut out more and more of
their employees leaving the consequences
for someone to deal with later on if
using AI makes a company 20% more
productive then they can fire 20% of
their employees and maintain the same
output people won't even know it's AI
either they'll just get fired for quote
underperforming instead on this path
we'll see an outcry of big changes like
self-driving trugs but the small changes
that make the difference when you put
them together will go unnoticed the
media will blame the same TD old issues
while more people get pushed out of the
system every day in this future the
profits from AI won't go to the people
who need them corrupt governments will
be paralyzed by lobbyists making sure
the corporations are keeping their
profits in check meanwhile they'll go
bankrupt trying to deal with millions of
newly unemployed people without those
jobs people simply won't have enough
money to keep the economy going crime
will Skyrocket as people go into
desperation taxes will barely be paid
police officers Stripped Away from the
streets and Anarchy and lawlessness
takes over Society the relative value of
human labor plummets meaning almost
everybody shut out of the economy
without anything to keep themselves
afloat apart from stealing from one
another fending for themselves and
sending whatever they can to survive
which is an absolute recipe for chaos
people won't have anything to gain so
they won't have anything to lose they'll
vote for whoever says they'll make make
things better the people offering the
simplest Solutions it means a rise in
extremism that will lead to unrest and
eventually revolutions and even
dictatorship and fascism or if it swings
the other way around communism now it
might seem like that's far away but all
it takes is enough hungry people to
upend the entire system suddenly the
reality the social norms that we live in
today just won't be able to exist key
government services like policing
ambulances Law and Order will just be
abstract Concepts that have no relevancy
and eventually the economic scales will
tip back the other way just like they
always have but it would take decades
and it's impossible to say how many
casualties there will be along the way
dude this guy nailed it this guy's
channel is called Moon just simply Moon
he's got amazing documentaries and what
he said makes complete sense when AI
takes all these jobs man the economy is
going to plummet and when you got hungry
starving people there's going to be
riots chaos people are going to vote for
whoever makes the best promises it can
be Satan
himself people will bow the neede to
Satan himself when the world is crippled
and brought to this place of
desperation I don't know
why any Bible believing Christian can't
see that this is what's going to happen
how they really believe that one man put
in office is going to fix all of this
and is going to change the agendas of
Satan who's in control the Bible says
he's the God of this world and I'm
giving you this message not to put fear
in you not to bash any person not to you
know break your heart or crush your
dreams or whatever this is just to show
you that Bible is real prophecy is true
I believe Jesus is coming in our
lifetime somebody in the chat said they
believe that they's coming in in 10
years I don't know if we got 10 years
this AI thing is evolving every day and
I can't do it justice in this video to
show you how crazy this is I would never
want to sponsor or promote Shane Dawson
on this channel but he just made a video
that dropped a day ago and it's got
600,000 views and it's about Ai and it's
full of foul language and everything but
if you can get past that and see what he
the information he's showing you is
terrifying because it's really what's
happening while we're all distracted and
we're eating our McDonald's and we're
playing our video games and binge
watching our favorite shows on Netflix
this stuff is happening and it's real
and we need to get right with Christ we
need to be ready we don't need to be
getting ready we need to be
ready it says when all these things
happen fear not lift up your heads
because the end is near that Christ is
coming soon I believe that with all my
heart and I want to be ready I'm not
perfect I'm trying to get there I'm
trying to bring as many people with me
as possible I want us to all be there I
want us to all be on the same page and
surrendering our life to Christ daily
picking up our cross daily and denying
the lust of the flesh whatever that is
whether it's you know adultery things or
whether it's addictions of to games or
substances whatever it is surrender
those things to God and he will take
them out of your life he's waiting on us
it's all about surrender I was an addict
I was a alcoholic and a weed head and I
was doing all the things that I
shouldn't have done and I new years's
2013 I surrendered something that I
couldn't give up on my own I tried and
tried and tried and failed every time
and when I
surrendered Jesus set me free overnight
supernaturally he's waiting on us to
give him permission to take it out of
our Lives he's not a thief he's not
bashing indoors he's knocking on the
door of your heart and he's waiting on
you to hand it over and say take it I
don't want it
anymore I pray that someone here makes
that decision that they wake up and say
wait a minute this stuff makes sense it
nothing changes no matter who's in
office I believe this is bigger than the
president I believe this is what the
Bible says that Satan's the God of this
world and that prophecy really happening
if that's
you please drop a comment tell me that
this was eye opening encouraging in some
way because we need to hear that too
this these types of messages are not
easy to give we need some feedback and
so if you like this video click a thumbs
up it really helps it get into the
algorithm if you're new to this channel
click subscribe because we're going to
come out with new videos like this all
the time they're not always going to be
about politics but it's always going to
be related somehow to the Bible or to
your spiritual walk the pagan origins of
things that we participate in all the
time we really appreciate your your love
and support if you want to support this
channel you can do so through cash app
through vinmo through zel you can go to
our website which is candid truth.org
there's a donate button there to um send
some donations through PayPal you can
even do monthly that way if you like
cool t-shirts we have T-shirts if you go
to candid truth.org just click on the
button that says shop or merch or
something like that check out our shirts
we get like $5 Commission on every shirt
that we sell that we designed and
they're all about um scripture or the
truth or it's cool to use your brain
because the world doesn't want you to
think Satan doesn't want you to use your
brain he wants you to be deceived and so
here at candid truth we say it's cool to
use your brain we're going to talk about
the truth and we're going to get candid
with it I love you guys thank you so
much for being here thank you guys for
supporting this Channel and we'll see
you next time on candid truth